it's the Friday before the Grammys do
you know where your kids are jamming out
to our new music Friday pig's death
happy Friday friends we have made it to
the weekend and as promised we have a
special guest for you today me sorry my
guest bailed last minute so you're stuck
with me
but it is Friday which means there are
plenty of new tracks and videos to
discuss I told myself I wasn't gonna
cover Justin Timberlake's next drop but
then I watched his video for his latest
single say something featuring Chris
Stapleton
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh I'm feeling that one one take live
vocals and a quarter this was better JT
all right the video was filmed at Los
Angeles landmark the Bradbury Building
it seemingly shot in one ticking can
tell from JT's a mic pack these dudes
and the choir are singing live so epic
Justin's collab with Chris of course is
featured on his new album man of the
woods out two days before his Superbowl
halftime performance meanwhile Drake
just broke both Spotify and Apple musics
record for the most stream song in a
single day with his latest single God's
plan might go down to GOG I go hard on
Southside G right I made sure that no
side he still clearly fans can't wait
for the new music I can't wait for the
new music God's plan is off his scary
hours project and Drizzy celebrated his
latest feat by posting this Instagram
with LeBron James who broke a record of
his own entering the 30,000 point Club
Drake wrote congrats key savesies and
finally the collaboration you never knew
you needed Zedd and gray teamed up with
country star Maren Morris for a
one-of-a-kind mash-up called the middle
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
now if you love that then make sure you
tune in to Sunday's Grammy Awards where
they will debut what is being called a
visually spectacular commercial for
their new single as part of targets
hashtag more music campaign now speaking
of the Grammys the big show airs Sunday
night live coast-to-coast on CBS Jay Z
lead the pack with eight nominations
followed by Kendrick Lamar with seven
jay-z is also nominated with Beyonce for
their collab Family Feud and we know for
sure they are going to be there we
spotted their seating cards inside
Madison Square Garden where the Grammys
will take place but the lingering
question is whether or not Jay will hit
the stage and will he perform with
Beyonce while he went straight to the
source host James Corden here's what he
had to say about the potential
performance from the Carters she won't
be performing this year no no pop out
with jay-z the most nominated gentleman
of the night what to perform with him I
don't think he's performing either so I
think they'll be there but I don't think
I don't enjoy Z's performing great but
you just see him backstage I guess yeah
I imagine he will have a pass yeah I
can't tell how serious Corden is about
that or if that's just his poker face
I'm holding out for Beyonce and jay-z to
hit the stage Sunday night but it is a
range impact with some other amazing
performances and you'll be breaking down
the Grammys most talked about moments
live right after the show ends at 80 now
on Twitter and on our YouTube channel so
make sure you're following us so you
don't miss out and I'll see you guys I'm
Grammy Sunday what am I gonna wear I'm
gonna go